this is the black hole that keeps on
giving it certainly is yes what's your
latest news yeah so you may remember
there was the first ever picture of a
black hole uh came out in
well almost two years ago now the event
horizon telescope folk have been
beavering away actually with the same
data to extract even more information
from it
and the results of that just came out
just published in astrophysical journal
letters a couple of days ago
it's one of the most massive black holes
we know about so it's about a billion
times the mass of the sun a really
really massive black hole in the middle
of messier 87 in the virgo cluster
and it turns out even though it's not
the closest one we could be looking at
it's it's because it's so massive its
influence is over
as large a region as any other and so
actually it's a really good one to look
at because it's you know it's a very
massive black hole which means its event
horizon is big which means that even
though it's a reasonable distance away
the telescope can still resolve what's
going on and it seems we've gone from
blurry orangeness to swirling orangeness
well the the so the swirliness is
a
a little bit of a trick in that it's
really just a way of visualizing what's
going on let me show you what they
actually measured which doesn't look
anywhere near as pretty
so here's what they actually measured
and it's basically instead of just
measuring the brightness of this ring of
light around the black hole they're
measuring this effect called
polarization light is made up of an
electric field and a magnetic field if
you just think about the electric field
for a moment it's oscillating away
that's what an electromagnetic wave is
it's an oscillation of that electric and
magnetic field but of course it could
oscillate up and down or left and right
and so the polarization is basically
telling you what direction the light is
oscillating in and that's essentially
what they measured in this picture is
that they basically measured that where
not only can they tell you how bright
the light is from every point in in the
surroundings of this black hole but they
can tell you what direction it's
polarized in as well i guess the first
thing to say is is it's it's a complete
tour de force of actually extracting
this information right just making the
picture at all was an amazing thing to
do but now they've gone beyond that to
actually extract this polarization
information remember they were combining
radio telescopes all around the world
and correlating all that data together
to produce this amazing image and then
once they've done all that now they've
got kind of gone back and done it all
again but but not only are they now
measuring the light but they're actually
telling us about the way that that light
is polarized and that involves combining
the polarization information that
they've again received from all these
individual uh radio dishes all around
the world so just getting a measurement
of the effect at all it's an amazing
thing to do but now that they've
measured it they can actually start
learning something about the process of
accretion onto the black hole the big
part of the reason why we're interested
and why particularly we're interested in
polarization
is because we know that messier 87 this
galaxy produces a jet flying out from
the center which is clearly associated
with the blacks this black hole it's a
phenomenon we've seen in lots of other
galaxies i think m87 was the first
galaxy it was ever actually seen in in
about 1918 so it's a phenomenon that's
been known about for a very long time
but we think that the process of
shooting that jet out is something to do
with the magnetic fields that the
magnetic fields are getting all tangled
and twisted up that twisting of the
magnetic field lines is what's
accelerating the particles out to
produce this jet
okay now the nice thing is that the
emission that you see
uh where there are magnetic fields is
this thing called synchrotron emission
where you've got electrons whizzing
around the magnetic field lines
that emission is polarized and so this
detection of polarization is telling us
something about the magnetic field
structure around the black hole because
the fact that it's polarized is almost
certainly associated with synchrotron
emission and the direction of the
polarization is telling us something
about the magnetic fields and the
strength of the polarization is telling
us something about the magnetic fields
too is the magnetic field that appears
to be around this black hole
at m87 exactly what we would have
expected has this confirmed what the
theorist said or has it thrown any
curveballs at us
a bit of both actually i mean the fact
that it's there at all is good news
there are two things so the the two
things that kind of come out from this
so there were actually two papers
there's a paper with the observations in
this paper of the theory and the kind of
the things that fed into the theory
paper from the observation paper are
firstly the directions of the
polarization which is kind of in this
sort of
the sort of the polarization is kind of
oriented around
the image
rather than radially inwards or radial
outwards it's kind of curling around the
image and the second is the strength of
the of the polarization so let's start
with the strength of the polarization
it's not actually that strongly
polarized right if you look at the scale
here the colors here are telling you the
strength of the polarization and it's
like point you know so they're sort of
bluish in color so it's about a tenth
polarized
thing about synchrotron radiation is
it's incredibly strongly polarized it
should be in a sort of 70 80 polarized
and we're only seeing 10 polarization
probably what's going on there is
there's another piece of physics a thing
called faraday rotation which is that
when polarized light passes through a
plasma and a magnetic field its
polarization gets rotated around
and so what we think's happening here is
that there's kind of a quite a
complicated mess of magnetic fields and
and plasma
between us and where the stuff is being
emitted
and that is sort of messing up the
polarization so even if the stuff will
very strongly polarize when it was first
produced some of it gets rotated a bit
some of it gets rotated the other way
some of it doesn't get rotated at all so
the net effect of that is that we lose a
lot of that polarization information so
this is telling us straight away the
strength of the of the polarization or
the relative actually weakness of the
polarization is telling us that there's
a lot going on that we haven't yet
resolved that's kind of within what we
can see and the net effect of that is
that we don't see so much polarization
so that's the first half of the story um
the second half of the story i guess we
need to switch to the theory paper
and they did a whole other
a really long complicated paper where
they describe the modeling they've done
to try to reproduce the results that
they were seeing
but interestingly the kind of the gist
of it comes from one of the first
figures in the paper
so this is a figure from the from the
theory paper where they look at what
would happen what you'd expect to see if
you had a toroidal magnetic field that's
a magnetic field which is kind of going
around and around the black hole the
same way the material is going around
the black hole
a radial magnetic field so that's a
magnetic field sticking in towards the
black hole or radially outwards from the
back hole
and a vertical magnetic field that's one
that's sticking up through this disc of
material that's orbiting around the
black hole
and what you can see is that the one
that really doesn't fit at all is the
toroidal one because the toroidal one
says the polarization should all be
pointing radially inwards or outwards
and yet what we actually saw in the data
is that the polarization is actually
more or less going around so that's what
you expect from the radial magnetic
field or the vertical magnetic field
and the reason why that's interesting is
that a toroidal magnetic field is what
you'd expect if what was going on is
you've got a whole load of material
that's orbiting around and it's
basically carrying the magnetic field
with it because if it were carrying the
magnetic field with it that would have
the effect of kind of twisting the
magnetic field round and around and
around and you end up with the magnetic
field that kind of went round and around
the black hole
okay and this is saying that's not
what's happening
but the the material can't be carrying
the magnetic field with it the only time
that doesn't happen is if the magnetic
field is so strong that it actually says
no i'm not going that way and so
actually it's strong enough to actually
resist the the pull of all the material
going around with it
um
and that happens when the magnetic field
so mainly it feels weird in that they
actually act a little bit like a gas
they can kind of exert pressure of their
own
so magnetic field lines for example if
you think about magnetic fields those
kind of magnetic field lines they don't
get it like getting pushed very close
together and so they actually use a
pressure back and what this is saying is
that this magnetic field must be so
strong that the pressure terms that just
come from the magnetic field and
itself are strong enough to resist the
gas and not get carried along with the
gas
so that's telling you it's weird the
polarization measurement sort of says
says actually the magnetic fields can't
be
we're not seeing that much effect of a
strong magnetic field because of these
weird faraday rotation effects but this
other piece of evidence is saying
actually the underlying magnetic field
what's producing it in the first place
is very very strong that was a sort of a
toy model just them looking at what they
would expect to see qualitatively in the
rest of the paper they went in on in
excruciating detail to look at a whole
bunch of detailed simulations to see if
they did and you've got to feed in
magnetic fields gas physics and general
relativity so they're incredibly
complicated simulations to do but they
basically compared the observations to a
whole bunch of these simulations which
sort of confirms that qualitative
picture and the only things that they
can get to fit
are things that they call mad disks
and a mad disk is a magnetically
arrested disk mad stands for a
magnetically arrested disk which
basically means the magnetic field is
strong enough to stop the disk in its
tracks and so instead of thinking of the
gas just orbiting around it actually
gets pulled to a halt by the magnetic
field pressure and will then end up sort
of following the magnetic field and
falling into the black hole rather than
just following a simple orbit around as
we'd expect from a simple disk picture
so that classic animation we always see
of black holes with a kind of swirling
disc around it might not be what they
look like at all not in this inner part
of the disc and bear in mind they really
are very close to the event horizon the
black hole so probably that picture is
right on the larger scale that there is
indeed material swirling around in
something that looks a bit like a disc
this is saying that actually when you
get right to that final moment as stuff
is arriving at the black hole the
picture must change and the material
probably isn't swirling around it's
being pulled along and along the
magnetic field lines rather than going
around in nice circular orbits professor
what's actually generating the magnetic
field at a black hole
magnetic fields are everywhere right and
and what probably what's happening is
that what's going on around the black
hole is just concentrating magnetic
fields as you pull the material in
you pull the magnetic fields with it
remember when you're not in this
situation where the magnetic fields
pressure is strong enough to resist this
magnetic fields tend to just follow the
material they get sort of sucked along
with it so as the material gets pulled
towards the black hole it pulls the
magnetic field with it and that sort of
concentrates the magnetic field lines so
you start from this very weak magnetic
field at large radii but by the time
you're getting closer to the black hole
you can have quite intense magnetic
fields so the black hole itself hasn't
got a magnetic field the way that the
earth does or the sun does and like that
no and in fact it fundamentally can't
because nothing can emerge from a black
hole you can't even have magnetic field
lines emerging from the black hole
itself so it's actually not possible for
the black hole itself to kind of sprout
magnetic field lines this thing called
the no hair theorem right that you can't
actually put hair onto a black hole and
this is the same thing that you can't
have magnetic field lines sprouting out
from a black hole so the magnetic fields
are all outside the black hole itself
and professor that headline image that
we've all seen over the last couple of
days that orangy one with the cool lines
coming out of it you kind of hinted that
maybe that's sort of his bit of a fudge
is it to sort of map the data in a
pleasing way
it's exactly it's a way of visualizing
so as i say what they actually measured
was was this thing with the with the
little lines and so on what they've come
up with is a really nice way of
visualizing that kind of swirly effect
in interpolating between the points
where they've got measurements just to
give you a way of kind of visualizing
the data in a way and it's not you know
it's not something that's just being
produced for publicity purposes it's
actually when they start trying to
compare their models with the data that
visualization putting their their models
in the same way the same kind of
visualization as the data is a really
nice way of qualitatively comparing them
and see what matches up and what doesn't
so if i drew out to m87 in my spaceship
and parked at a respectable distance
would i see anything like what that
picture looks like
i no you wouldn't see that swirly
picture
i mean you you know you see some pretty
dramatic things i think but
and you might even see some of the
effects of the magnetic field because
just like if you think about those
beautiful pictures that you get of the
sun where you see the plasma flowing
along the magnetic field lines of the
sun you could well be seeing those kind
of phenomena where the plasma around the
black hole is flowing along the magnetic
fields and really picking them out so
you could actually effectively see the
magnetic field lines but they wouldn't
look i don't think quite like those
visualizations and lastly professor you
indicated that this data is the original
data they used before just analyzed in a
new way why does it take so long
it's because it's a so you really got to
check every possible there are lots of
possible systematic things that can
creep in there are lots of things that
can mess up your data so they spend a
lot of time calibrating the data making
sure they really understood the data
making sure there wasn't anything left
in the data that was not associated you
know that was not astrophysical but was
to do with their telescopes so there's a
huge amount of processing and then
actually computationally you know just
actually analyzing the data producing
these maps doing all the simulations
it's a huge amount of work so it's taken
more or less all this time just to get
from the point of producing that first
image and even in that first image they
knew there was polarization information
there but to go from that to actually
being able to do something quantitative
saying this is how big the polarization
is this is how it's oriented it's a
massive work which is why it's taking
quite a while to get here i know i ask
you this all the time but there's a
great big supermassive black hole
presumably right on our doorstep at the
center of our own milky way can we just
not get a good enough look at it
in fact so there's there is i mean it's
much smaller than one in the middle of
m87 it's in you know in the millions of
solar masses rather than the billions of
solar masses but you know it's a
thousand times closer so actually the
scale of things is the same
interestingly it's i think i mean and
they've been trying to produce a picture
of the of the black hole in the middle
of the milky way as well with the the
event horizon telescope um
the reason why it's difficult is this
faraday rotation thing that actually the
the maybe the things emitting you know
beautifully polarized light around from
around the black hole but actually
between us and the center of the galaxy
there's a whole bunch of magnetic fields
associated with the galaxy which really
messes up the uh the radio emission plus
this interstellar medium which causes
scintillations it's just a lot harder to
look at our own
uh black hole in the middle of our own
galaxy because we're peering through all
the things between us and the center of
the galaxy we should just mess up the
picture whereas m87 is well out of the
plane of the galaxy so there's really
not much us between us and m87 and so we
get a much clearer view of something
which is sort of the same size at least
in terms of angle which makes it a much
easier thing to look at
the black hole onto what we call the
accretion disk which is sort of the
bathtub of water that's trying to spiral
in you've almost merged the two plug
holes so you've made the plug hole
bigger so not only have you grown the
black hole in that way you've then
almost made it easier for it to create
more material right because you've made
it so that it has a bigger gravitational
pull